on poursuit avec sébastien lavoie
économiste en chef chez valeurs
mobilières banque laurentienne bonsoir
monsieur lavoie
alors 8,1 pour cent en juin encore une
inflation soutenue propulsé en bonne
partie par les sens c'est ce qu'on est
ce qu'on doit jeter tout le blâme sur la
russie encore une fois pour cette
inflation élevée
non non pas du tout c'est sûr que la
russie ajoute beaucoup dans la mesure où
dansaient aux transports on essaie de
passer des surcharges essentielle ment
plusieurs détaillants mais la réalité
c'est qu'on en d1 montrer différents os
sécurisé de l'offre causes justes de
l'offre au niveau énergétique
alimentaire mais à tous les niveaux
françois que les entreprises et
entrepreneurs ont totalement changé son
jeu de stratégie ans dans l'isolément à
son bord des consommateurs qui veulent
des biens des services va falloir qu'ils
payent pour donc sécurisé de l'offre
c'est une nouvelle crise on veut dans
l'économie d'aujourd'hui donc des
pressions qui pour l'inflation venait de
l'extérieur pendant un bon moment mais
là ce sont des pressions intérieures
maintenant l'inflation est bien ancré
dans l'économie c'est ce qu'on comprend
oui on leur manque au niveau de tout ce
qui est service donc les salaires
augmentent c'est comme s'il y avait une
nouvelle vague niveau facteur clé
renchérir l'inflation canada et ce qui
fait qu'ils quinzaine canadienne tu nous
écoutes bien son probable de rattraper
un peu comme un marathonien la ligne
d'arrivée qui s'éloigne de plus en plus
et en permettant de sommets c'est sûr
qu'avec quelques aspects du rapport
d'aujourd'hui qui était quand même
intéressant aux emails et prochaine son
nouveau de des prix va être un peu moins
dur pour les consommateurs mais ça va
prendre encore beaucoup de temps va
rattraper le temps perdu des deux
derniers mais ce qu'on comprend pas ce
que vous l'aviez évoquées au printemps
entre autres on disait ben on pourrait
avoir atteint un sommet peut-être en
juin pour l'inflation je comprends votre
message on y serait peut-être au sommet
ça pourrait s'apaiser encore un peu oui
c'est certainement un départ d'avoir un
sommet même si la façon vont rester
élevés encore pour plusieurs mois et
même plusieurs trimestres et une dizaine
du capteur invite les gens à regarder ce
sont des universitaires américains
qui ont une excellente mesure des
pressions au niveau des chaînes de
transport à l'échelle mondiale en salle
à diminuer au cours des mois de mai et
juin est typiquement dans les mois
suivants ben tout ce qui commande de
biens importés au canada a tendance à
aller dans le même sens tu donc à ce
moment là ça pourrait être un des
éléments clés lors ou deux premiers se
met ensuite ainsi les hausses de
salaires ne sont pas trop féroce on veut
pour la suite des choses à ce moment là
on peut avoir un mouvement un peu plus
généralisée je voudrais vous en finance
à perdre un peu les présents ont
présentement sur le revenu disponible
des gens après inflation ce qu'on voit
par contre monsieur la voici que les
dépenses de consommation sont toujours
au rendez vous est-ce que ça alimente
l'inflation faut aussi mettre en
contexte là il ya bien des canadiens qui
ont amassé beaucoup d'épargnants si on
fait un bon coussin pendant la pandémie
on paie jeu là dedans en ce moment pour
faire face à l'augmentation des coûts
est ce que c'est une source d'inquiétude
pour vous
non dans la mesure où ceux qui utilisent
l'appareil excessive c'est des gens qui
en ont besoin pour payer juste à main
certaines factures est arrivé à la fin
du mois et quand on est seul chez nous
la banque laurentienne qu'à environ le
un cinquième 20 % de l'épargné excessive
qui était vraiment s'ils sont venus
durant la pandémie quelle de dépenser
jusqu'à maintenant cette année à cause
d'un façon plus élevé je voudrais que
les consommateurs ont quand même changé
leurs habitudes ce parce qu'elles sont
juste que l'inflation que le prix orange
c'est au niveau des prix tellement élevé
confiance ces comportements grandi dans
une phase de précaution ce qui devrait
déflationniste point facile
puisqu'on parle de déflationniste le
logement qui est à peu près une des
seules composantes dont la croissance
amble s'essouffler encore assez peu là
est-ce qu'elle avec la récente hausse
des taux hypothécaires retour directeur
évidemment hypothécaires ensuite un
ralentissement des mises en chantier ce
qu'on est ce qu'on va finir par voir un
ralentissement plus plus importants
d'ici la fin de l'année
oui mais il ya déjà un compte ce pas
surpris que la baisse des prix au cours
des prochains mois soit encore plus tant
que quelques celle qu'on a eu évidemment
compte tenu de la hausse serait très
apprécié laurent du canada la semaine
dernière est ce que je change ici c'est
la perception des gens et suis bien
content parce que bien des études qui
ont montré que finalement il ya trop de
gens qui essaient de passer à travers la
même porte en 2020 2021 pour acheter la
même maison donc on est en train de
revenir dans un des conditions un peu
plus sûres et plus saines sauveur mais
compte tenu que l'offre chronique pour
rester un problème pour quoi s'attendre
à ce que le prix des maisons baissent de
25 30% à contrairement à ce que d'autres
économistes concernant vous dire dans
l'audition on ne peut plus de l'ordre
d'idée avant que j'entre en scène que la
bei finalement en co2 km
au cumulatif 12 15 % ou 6 % c'est
difficile à dire mais recalibré tous les
bienvenus en quelque sorte et redonner
redorer un peu ce qu'on attendait depuis
longtemps c2d consomment beaucoup plus
équilibré bon si je comprends bien votre
message certains éléments s'améliore la
banque centrale elle vise un retour à
une inflation à 3% vers la fin 2023 est
ce que ça vous paraît réaliste le en
prenant compte qu'on aura
vraisemblablement un taux directeurs
autour de 3,3 et demi pour cent la fin
de l'année
j'ai de la difficulté à croire encore
que l'inflation va revenir dans une
fourchette acceptable tous les canadiens
et canadiennes
même en 2024 la bande sonore de vie sur
deux pour cent essentiellement ce qu'on
se rend compte c'est que le chum
christian paire de ferme à nouveau
certaines instruments facturées alors la
prochaine vague locaux vides toute la
question des gens déjà la question
géopolitique on veut produire et plus
proche de chez nous mais construire ce
que tu cher donc on revient tout le
temps à la case départ que tout a
quelque chose du coup trop tard quelque
part soit pour construire soit pour
changer nos habitudes
soit pour être un peu plus efficace une
audition d'un montage donc à ce moment
là je suis en train de me dire que non
seulement les façons d'être plus élevé
3% la félonie 2023 mais également
supérieurs 2% 2024 non sans dire que
c'est la stagflation des années 66 aie
aie pas est possible que finalement le
tour de france on en revienne parce que
les gens sont habitués c'est à dire lors
de deux pour sa forme et dans ce
contexte si je comprends bien ça on a
une inflation qui plus soutenue qui
réagit moins rapidement à des hausses de
taux d'intérêt la banque du canada
pourrait elle aussi son taux directeur
plus rapidement et risquer une récession
je pense que le message de hausser les
taux plus rapidement le bien compris la
semaine dernière ce n'est pas du que le
sommet des taux est plus élevé et à
quelques heures je l'attendrai ce que la
banque du canada ce que le corner suite
m'incline réalise que bon il va voir je
suis à un moment donné à refroidir
l'inflation qui est d'ordre cycliques un
peu comme dans l'immobilier quand on
vient discuter mais les éléments plus
structurelle et mondiaux mais on peut
pas faire grand chose comme ça c'est pas
le remède de monter les taux par exemple
à 4 5% comme certains économistes comme
les russes hommage aux etats-unis
vont-ils vous convaincre donc je serais
surpris qu'on aille a vraiment plus haut
que 3 3 car au niveau d'août secours du
recteur et de toute façon l'itu marchés
us sont beaucoup plus restrictif que le
taux directeur de la banque du canada
donc juste en parlant avec les actions
la banque du canada fait déjà un peu le
travail
monsieur lavoie merci beaucoup pour vos
explications
le fait que les aimants soir à peu pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]